meine name ist ina pagani beim bau der
wert war ich tät ich alles für
bauingenieure monate früher gesagt die
einzige frau die in tunnel sein darf ist
die heilige barbara weiler in eine
andere frau in den tunnel geht dann
könnte die heilige barbara würden werden
und sie würde dann die mineure nicht
mehr schützen und das war das glauben
in der ausbildung wurde nach 20 jahren
ich kam vor dem portal und dann stand
dort ein polier und ermittlern gesagt
dass die frauen zuständig in den tunnel
ich habe dann gedacht das ist ein scherz
und ich habe dann gemerkt nein das war
kein scherz
eine frau geht nicht rein
er wird irgendwann sind jetzt den frauen
gekommen in dieser männerwelt und dann
hat man das regeln können müsse mit der
heiligen barbara
sie akzeptiert und gut
in teilabschnitten tätig dort war eben
eine ganz schwierige geologische sohn
erwartet wo das druck hafte gebirge
vorhanden war
beim druck auf das gebirge das spezielle
ist eigentlich dass man wird ein loch
und
dann mit dem drucker geht das loch
wieder zusammen
ein teil davon zumindest weil diese
abschnitte müsste man so ganz spezielle
stahlbögen ein waren das waren so bogen
die aus zwei mal acht elemente waren die
sich eigentlich zusammen gedrückt haben
wir den glauben dass diese deformation
stattfindet dass der tunnel sicher bis
zu einem meter vierzig im durchmesser
verkleinern ohne dass das sieht was
passiert
das war ganz speziell für alle für alle
die unten tätig war
es hat sich in diese bogen dann spannung
aufgebaut und irgendwann sind dann
gerutscht
die zwei profile ineinander und kritik
so geknallt und ist speziell wenn man
denkt man hat er über 1000 meter fels
über den kopf des kanals erste mal war
ein bisschen so ziemlich speziell
logisch sie haben dann bisschen so
geschaut ob wir alle ruhig waren unter
und immer noch sicher waren das war das
richtige system und aber man hat schnell
gemerkt es passiert nichts oder
insbesondere es passiert genau was wir
wollten das ist passiert oder das musste
die bürger müssten sich bewegen und er
ist in große stahlprofile und er ist
macht einfach dieses kleinen als wir
gemerkt haben
wir schaffen durch den tz im norden
diese spezielle geologische zone mit dem
zugkräftigen gebirge das war das war
schön das war eine ein gutes gefühl nach
nach viele versuche nach viel arbeiten
ganz wunderbar wäre
das moment mit vielen emotionen ist der
durchschlag oder wenn man tunnel
eröffnete sie in die tunnelbauer lang
weg dann sind andere spezialisten
gekommen und haben vielleicht zwei drei
vier jahren daran gearbeitet man ist weg
sicher das erste mal wo ich durch fahren
werde wenn ich schon viel emotionen
fühlen weil wir sind hin und der lange
gelaufen
in diesen stunden bevor es der richtige
tun war